FTX collapsed overnight and more stuff
like this is going to happen in the
upcoming recession oftentimes banking
institutions Etc over leverage meaning
they basically gamble people's money
people like us who put money in the bank
and so here's an easy thing that you can
do to protect yourself against that
instead of going to Banks instead of
putting your money in Banks you can
actually buy treasury bonds which are
both safer and pay four percent rather
than point zero zero zero one percent
like Banks do anybody can do this and
the nice thing is you can trade in and
out of them instantly so they're still
liquid but what I recommend doing is
actually waiting for them to come do and
just buy 6 12 18 24s and then waiting
six months once that comes due take the
money and the interest and buy another
24 month that way you're always cycling
and getting new cash in and it's safe